meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
ich melde mich hier aufgezeichnet aus
der Lindenstraße in der ARD wo gerade
eine aufwendige Szene gedreht wird über
die ich aber gar nicht sagen darf weil
hier immer alles vor Ausstrahlung streng
geheim ist nicht geheim ist aber worüber
ich mit den arzen im Interview sprechen
werde unter anderem warum pornap
beschränkt ist warum aze was positives
ist und welche Interviews sie von
klickum schon gesehen haben und
natürlich noch viel viel mehr wenn er
nichts verpassen wollt genau abonnieren
nicht vergessen bis dann bleib
dran wir hier bei klickom jetzt mit dem
sensationellen Interview von uns die
zzen ihr habt kckstum schon auf dem
Schirm gehabt ihr habt was gesehen was
habt ihr gesehen ach alles mögliche von
FLIR über Farid Bang sogar und die ganze
HipHop Fraktion und alles was es da gibt
natürlich also das wird ja immer überall
verlinkt und man sieht es immer hier und
da und ist schön dass wir uns jetzt mal
sehen ja mich freut das auch riesig also
wie gesagt ihr seid auf der Liste und
dann kommt ja der Moment da sagt man die
kommen jetzt dann arbeitet man sich ein
und dann äh dann war das witzige das
hatte ich überhaupt nicht auf dem Schirm
ihr kommt ja auch aus der hiphopeecke
was mir natürlich jetzt überhaupt nicht
nein
nein du nicht ja nicht
auf sagst ich ich sprü dafür Züge und
das gehört auch zuaktion wir sind sehr
starke hiphooper eigentlich also wir
kommen extrem aus der hiphopszene wir
sind wahrscheinlich mehr HipHop als
manche HipHop Rapper weil wir wir kommen
aus der graffitizene wir haben früher
gesprayt wir haben viel mit Breakdancern
zu tun gehabt wir hatten eine Zeit lang
sogar die BC Breaker bei uns gehabt wir
waren d gewesen wir rappen auch über
elektrob das ist ja auch wie als wenn
man zu i sagt du bist ja nur
Schauspieler obwohl der auch aus der
HipHop Fraktion kommt oder dein
Namensvetter also ja gut dein
Namensvetter Mar Mark ja Verg mit
Musik
genau aber der ist nicht so
HipHop der ist wirklich mehr
Schauspieler aber mit den zzen kam dann
der Durchbruch und vorher lief es
eigentlich auch ziemlich gut aber das
konnte man nicht verkaufen anders es
lief anders
verkauft also kann man nicht sagen also
viele Sachen im Untergrund laufen ja
besser als viele Leute das mitkriegen es
wird halt oft nicht bei der Media
Control gezählt weil die meisten Leute
keine Ahnung haben genau wie es bei uns
auch war wir haben einfach nur geguckt
dass wir unsere CDs verkaufen können
dann hat man so eine feste Fanbase und
die kaufen dann die Sachen das heißt ihr
konntet davon leben
ja
ein das gehört mit
dazu unser DJ DJ Klaus DJ Klaus auch aus
der hiphopszene na ja ja wir konnten
davon leben mal besser mal weniger aber
ein ich du musst es auch eine Strafe
zahlen ja das hat alles ins miese
gezogen ja natürlich also man macht auch
mal
minus weil pornap war das was du gemacht
hast ja so kann man es nennen ja ja so
wird's genannt oder ja auf jeden das war
porn Rap ja aber war schwierig schwierig
ja atzenmusik ist leichter funktioniert
besser er ist äh auch schwierig warum
ist das ist genauso geil also ich glaube
äh atmusik ist schon leichter ween man
halt mehr Themengebiete hat so man hat
natürlich auch so dieses Party Ding als
hauptding so aber wir sind halt auch
Künstler wir wollen halt kreativ sein
unds ausleben wo wir nur können deswegen
haben wir z.B auch beim letzten Album
ganz Rockalbum gemacht wo wir noch als
bonusesen Rockalbum gemacht haben weil
man will sich nicht nur immer auf ein
Thema beschränken und pornap ist sehr
beschränkt
z.B aber kommt gut an wie be oder
überhaupt Porno wenn man jetzt
Dschungelcamp oder so sieht ja Sex sals
ganz klar ja aber Party s better Party
auch weil ja die Leute wollen immer
feiern also Mr Mix von der TIF Crew der
auch eigentlich Porno Rapper ist mehr
oder weniger oder Produzent Produzent
oder DJ oder wie man es auch nennen mag
die haben ja auch einen anderen Begriff
dafür da heißt es ja Miami Base und die
der meinte einmal zu uns er mein E die
Leute wollen immer tanzen die wollen
immer feiern deswegen wird dancmusik
auch nie Aussterben das ist eigentlich
eine Musikrichtung die es immer geben
wird egal in welcher formm und wie ist
das bei euch wie ist es auf entstanden
ist das ein Zufall gewesen dass ihr in
diese Richtung gekommen seid oder war
das geplant so nach es gibt ja Leute die
planen die sagen Bo so den Style haben
wir und jetzt fangen wir an Vertrag und
los geht's war aber bei euch nicht so
oder ne nee wir haben nie was geplant
also wir haben im Endeffekt wir haben
auch Fußball Rap gemacht oder horrorraap
oder alles mögliche alles mal
durchprobiert genau es gibt ja Deuter
fußballrap horrorrap und so da gibt's
ganz viele verschiedene Alben und so
wenn man sich mal damit beschäftigt und
so weiter und so fort und dann haben wir
uns irgendwann mal ein Studio zusammen
gemietet haben dort zusammen musiziert
und haben auch ganz viele alte Geräte
aus den 80er Jahren zu gesammelt und
wirklich denn mal hart gearbeitet an dem
Album wo wir alles zusammen mischen und
dann ist aen Musik Volume 1 entstanden
und das ist ein reines Party Album
geworden ohne dass wir irgendwie ein
Major hatten oder irgendwas das war ein
einf ein reines partyalbum was so
entstanden ist wo ein ganz normaler Atze
drauf ist wo das geht ab drauf ist wo
Florida Lady auch drauf ist und so
weiter und sofort mit Alexander Markus
und das haben wir dann irgendwann durch
durch Alexander Markus dann auch Konto
angeboten und dann kam eins zum anderen
und dann Alexander Markus an den
erinnert man sich nicht mehr so aber ihr
seid der bringt ein Kinofilm raus nein
ich habe heute Trailer tra was passiert
denn in dem Kinofilm da tanzt die ganze
ich hab Gehör lieb Geschichte auch dabei
und so
jaustig okay ja aber es war nicht
geplant nee du hast recht also wir haben
wirklich wir haben einfach das gemacht
worauf wir Bock hatten zu einer Zeit wo
wir
frei waren also wir waren wirklich frei
musikalisch frei wir hatten wie gesagt
ich hatte da meine Anzeigen gehabt ich
hatte die Strafe gezahlt es war gerade
alles vorbei und wir hatten halt ein
Studio was heißt alles vorbei war das so
wo ihr dachtet ich komm ich krieg nie
ein Fuß
Fuß am Boden weil da kriege ich das
Problem da das läuft nicht das ist
schwierig das ist oder ne das war das
war eine Phase in der haben wir alles
gemacht wir haben sogar ein Album von
Megalo und sprachtod rausgebrachtt
zusammen Megalo ist in der hiphopszene
auch ziemlich bekannt als ein sehr guter
Rapper den irgendwie alle feiern aber
der irgendwie nie was an Start gebracht
hat bis jetzt wirklich so was die Leute
registriert haben aber er es zählt für
uns auf jeden Fall zu einem der besten
von dem haben wir z.B ein Album
rausgebracht alles Mögliche was wir
alles gemacht haben wir haben immer noch
die Festplatte voll mit Songs von damals
wo wir einfach experimentiert haben
einfach alles möglich gemacht haben und
da ist auch AZ Musik Volum 1 entstanden
wo wir einfach die besten Songs die wir
zu der Zeit gemacht haben die
zusammengepasst haben die so auch dieses
elektronische hatten auf ein Ding
raufgauen haben und
es hat funktioniert ganz komisch du du
sag oder du sagst es ist ein Lifestyle
ist das aus eurem Leben entstanden so
oder seid ihr so drauf Party Party Party
oder
was hat das mit Euch persönlich zu tun
das hat sich einfach so entwickelt also
wir haben einfach unser Ding
durchgezogen wie gesagt wir haben das
Album produziert wir sind damit auch zu
Konto gegangen haben unsere ersten Party
gefeiert und haben daran Gefallen
gefunden und irgendwie hat sich das wie
so ein Schmetterlings Effekt hat sich
das so entwickelt dass alle Leute sich
ja die haben das auch gefeiert und dann
wuren es immer mehr immer mehr und auch
diese ganze Mode und so weiterte
mal ja es war es war einfach ein Nichts
geplantes nichts irgendwie erfundenes
oder wie gesagt es ist einfach so
passiert es ist ja auch nicht so dass
wir von einem auf ein anderen Tag gesagt
haben wir ändern jetzt unsere Musik oder
was anderes es ist ja es ist ja trotzdem
noch genau dasselbe gewesen irgendwo es
waren noch dieselben Sounds wir arbeiten
immer noch mit 808 und haben noch dieses
typische Base dingmer drin wir kommen
aus dem Elektrobereich wir haben früher
angefangen als DJs Elektro aufzulegen
das heißt Egyptian laovera und dieses
ganze oldschol Zeug aus den 80ern und
haben irgendwann angefangen das Zeug zu
loopen eigene drum machines darüber zu
bauen und irgendwelche Sachen drüber zu
rappen die wir von toif Crew und NWA
aufgeschnappt haben und das auf deutsch
zu rappen und dann später das ist eine
Entwicklungsphase erzenmusik ist daraus
entstanden weil wir gesagt haben das ist
damit können wir uns identifizieren
genau wie du sagst seid ihr wirklich so
so wie dieses amerikanische Ding was man
halt kopiert erstmal am Anfang wenn man
Rapper ist ist man natürlich nicht und
man entwickelt sich immer mehr dahin
dass man so sein eigenes Ich findet als
Musiker und ich würde sagen zzenmusik
beschreibt eigentlich genau das was wir
sind weil wir haben ja auch ernste
Themen es ist natürlich die Leute kennen
oft nur die Singles discopogo das geht
ab sonst was aber wenn man sich die
Alben anhört da sind dann auch andere
Themen drauf oder man muss auch oft
zwischen den Zeilen lesen damit man
versteht was los ist oder was wir den
Leuten auch vermitteln wollen was hat
denn dieser oder Lifestyle den ihr
vermittelt oder wenn du sagst der dass
ich dass ich als Musiker gefunden habe
mit eurem privaten ich zu tun ist ist da
also ich habe letztlich mit der Kollegin
gesprochen die hat über ein
amerikanischen Star gesprochen mit dem
sie ein jah zusammen war das war kennt
man ja nicht war drüben Megastar und die
sagte das war furchtbar wenn der quasi
erkannt wurde hat er in dem Moment seine
Rolle geändert hat hier Fans hallo bin
ich ja und wie ha und Tralala und super
Stimmung in dem Moment aber schaltet der
hat zwischen privat und Beruf
umgeschaltet wie ist das bei euch was
hat das miteinander zu tun oder wo ist
da ist es ein weicher Übergang oder ist
das
wasag Tür geht zu privat Spießer
Gelsenkirchener Barock also eigentlich
hab eigentlich haben wir fast gar kein
Privatleben okay ja g ich nur ja sagen
ja nee eigentlich haben wir fast kein
Privatleben also natürlich braucht man
auch mal seine ruhphasen wo man
abschchealtet und so man sagt e ich kann
jetzt gerade nicht ich muss mal einfach
kurz für mich sein das hat ja jeder
Mensch irgendwie der irgendwie ein Beruf
auslebt oder so und bei uns s das Musik
machen irgendwie ein Beruf aber wir
machen es ja aus Leidenschaft es ist ja
nicht so dass wir irgendwie gesagt haben
wir machen das jetzt um irgendwie ein
Image darzustellen um damit irgendwie
Geld zu verdienen sondern wir haben die
Musik gemacht weil sie uns Spaß gemacht
hat und haben dann auf einmal damit
angefangen Geld zu machen und das ist
glaube ich ein ganz großer Unterschied
weil wenn irgendwann der Hype nicht mehr
da ist machen wir immer noch das was wir
machen und werden immer noch denselben
Spaß dran haben und wir feiern auch
unsere Partys und ich glaube das ist
auch das was uns so erfolgreich gemacht
hat dass die Leute gesehen haben dass
wir einfach die Partys gelebt haben auf
der Bühne immer und immer noch leben und
immer noch leben also D dass wir das nie
irgendwie gespielt haben oder dass wir
irgendwie den Leuten was vorgemacht
haben sondern dass wir immer natürlich
wenn du jetzt fünf kcks htereinander
spielst kannst du beim bei der fünften
Party nicht danach noch auf die
Afterparty gehen und mit jedem einzelnen
Fan ein Kippen und obwohl wir das auch
gemacht haben aber dann ist die Stimme
nicht mehr da ja da kannst du nächste
Woche nicht mehr auftreten da machst
dich selber fertig aber wir sind halt
auch privat immer alle miteinander und
wir sind halt eine riesen Posse und der
Traum wä natürlich ein riesengroßes Haus
wo alle wohnen und wo jeder auch mal
abschalten kann seine Zimmertür zumachen
kann und alle zusammen auch Musik machen
also ihr seid quasi eine männerwg auf
der Bühne ja auch Frauen wir haben ja
auch Frauen bei uns sind ja nicht nur
Männer sondern sind ja auch immer
Mädchen bei wir haben ja viele
Sängerinnen und auch so Freundin aber
die taucht nicht so im Cast tauchen die
nicht auf die Frauen wir haben Captain
Bambi jetzt gerade am Start das wechselt
immer also Captain Bambi oder Becky Boo
ist auch schon immer mit am Start aber
das sind halt auch Mädchen kennst ja
Frauen sind immer so die ziehen auch
immer ihr eigenes Ding irgendwo
durch
okay also ihr würde aber ihr würdet
gerne in der großen WG mit vielen Leben
das wäre euer ja ich sag das jetzt so
natürlich braucht jeder auch so sein
Eigenheim und jeder hat natürlich auch
so seinen eigenen Stil den erlebt und so
aber so ein so ein Dorf oder so so ein
kleines zzendorf wo alle Fantastischen
Vier die haben noch SAS ich weiß nicht W
nicht nur Thomas D auf auf Mars heißt
das ja
s Mar aber so W geil so ein Planet so
ein zzenplet Planet der zzen der Mars
wäre doch nicht schlecht ja okay wo dann
alle hinkommen können auch Fans wohnen
ist kein Ding okay gut sind ja auch
arzen die nennen wir eigentlich gar
nicht Fans wir nennen uns das ist ja
auch bei euch das ist ja das gibt's ja
glaube ich so nicht es gibt ja
merchandise bei euch ist aber gar kein
merchandise mehr sondern es ist e ein
Style es dient der Identifizierung also
man kann sagen ich identifiziere mich
jetzt ich bin Atze ich da steht dann
auch Atze drauf und dann heißt es ich
bin Atze was ist echter
Atze ein echterze du bist auch einze
also gut okay kann auch positiv oder ne
sein kann auch sagen hinten guck mal den
komischen zzen an was mit dem los weß so
ist ze immer ist eine Ansichtssache aber
zze kommt eigentlich ursprünglich aus
dem berlinerischen altberlinerischen 1us
mal erzählt ist eigentlich heißt es
Bruder das hat die Generation unserer
Väter oder Onkels hat sich gegenseitig
Bruder genannt so und wir haben dann
irgendwan umgedeutschen Kumpel steht
jetzt auch ein langcheid im im im
Wörterbuch drin steht jetztze steht
jetzt Kumpel und lustige Jugendkultur
die sich bunt kleiden oder steht drin
aber trotzdem steht für euch nicht Atze
für was für ein
bestimmten Freundschaft Amis und
Amerikaner oder die Engländer sagen ja
dude oder h oder Brother und so und in
Deutschland gab's ja außer in Hamburg
gab's ja mal dier aber sonst gab ja
nicht son sagt man ja hier kommt mein
freundau hört sich dann immer ein
bisschen doof an dann sagt man hier hier
kommen kommen meine arztten gerade also
es ist schon was positives ZTE ist
wirklich was positives so also du sagst
ete was los mit dir wei dann meint es so
von wegen freundlich weißt du sel wenn
ein Problem mit dem Typen gerade hast
und das noch dranzt dann kommt es
trotzdem noch nett rüber was denn los
weiß du wo istin Problem und dann merkt
er okay cool das ist ein Bruder das ist
ein Freund für mich gerade der will mich
gerade auf richtigen Weg leiten es
klingt ein bisschen anders als wenn du
sagst e diger was los kommt gleich was
willst du mich ankacken oder was
manchmal
schon kommt auf die Ton also im diger
meint ihr steht steckt eher etwas
Negatives ne ne Gott nicht
wirklich aber dier ist ein bisschen wie
Alter okay in Berlin sagt man jaim Alter
e Alter was los oder e diger und so das
ist so aber Atze bedeutet einfach immer
positiv eigentlich immer positiv auch
wenn man ein blöden Arzten anspricht ist
ist immer eigentlich schon ja eigentlich
immer genau weil sonst wä es kein Arzt
okay also das ist ja schon mal was was
ist von allem ander oder was ein wenig
eingrenzt okay was mich wundert ich
würde bei Partymusik immer denken die
machen das wegen des Geschäftes also wie
ein Schlagersänger der eigentlich am
liebsten mit tren genau sehr gute Frage
das ist gen genau das Erfolgskonzept
weil viele Fragen ja warum seid ihr den
so erfolgreich warum kommen die Leute
den zu euren Partys genau weil wir
dieses Dings halt leben diese Partys ja
weil die Leute sehen e die meinen es
ehrlich die Feiern wirklich gerne auf
der Bühne die Rasten wirklich gerne aus
sieh man uns an ja sieht man uns ja auch
an im Endeffekt ne ich habe dich ja
gerade gefragt sieht meine Augenringe ja
genau er kam mir rein und sagt sieht
meine Augenringe aber Endeffekt ich
scheiß drauf und so ich habe ja auch mal
ein hawaianisches frauenkostüm bei S
angehabt oder ein Huhn auf dem Kopf und
so jetzt sie ich richtig wie als wenn
ich drei Tage lang durchgemacht habe nur
die linke Seite von vorne ist egal im
Endeffekt ist drauf geschissen zze sein
sei einfach frei sei wie du bist und
mach dein Ding einfach so wie du dich
wohlfühlst und dann ist alles cool aber
geht euch das nicht manchmal auf die
Nerven weil ihr ihr werdet ja engagiert
um zzen zu sein um Party zu machen sagt
man nicht manchmal boah nee heute
eigentlich nicht es gibt wirklich es
gibt wirklich Tage an denen du sagst e
ich habe jetzt gar keinen Bock gerade
weiß also weil du wirklich fertig bist
körperlich nervlich ja manchmal hat man
auch so denkst du so ah jetzt gerade
Lärm und Menschen und so aber im
Endeffekt also bei mir ist es meistens
so wenn ich dann auf der Bühne bin dann
sieht's ganz anders aus immer dann ist
dann dann bin ich ein anderer Mensch in
dem Moment macht's Klick und dann ist
die Euphorie wieder wieder am Start egal
wie fertig bin ich bin egal wie kaputt
ich bin also und woher kommt die
Euphorie von den Leuten von den Menschen
weil wenn wenn wenn da wirklich 500 oder
1000 oder 10000 wir haben ja auch sogar
schon mal vorm Brandenburgertor vor
einer Million Leute aufgetreten und dann
wirklich dein Namen
rufenenen dann denkst du wow krass und
dann ist egal wie schlecht es dir geht
du feierst D mit den okay was passiert
dann was spürt man dann wenn eine
Million oder
100000egal das ist 100 sein oder 50
mein das ist dann wie so ein weiß ich
nicht das ist so ein Adrenalinschub
Schauer über den Rücken genau so
Krippeln im Nacken bei mir krippel ja
manchmal so hier hinten bisschen trinkst
du ein Bierchen und dann geht's hier
richtig los und dann wird die geht's
hier richtig ab ne es ist ein bisschen
wie eine Droge ja also bei mir auf jeden
Fall also ich bin absolut süchtig nach
Musik ich glaube kann ich auch für Mark
Spen süchtig nach Musik nach Party und
nach nach diesen ganzen Shows also es
ist manchmal bei mir so wenn ich dann
wirklich einen Monat mal frei hab was
eigentlich fast nie vorkommt oder ein
halben Monat dann brauche ich das
irgendwie also irgendwie fehlt's mir ich
merke dass es mir fehlt natürlich
ist es auch immer anders ob es jetzt
riesenshows sind oder kleine Shows wir
machen ja alles W man wirklich vom
kleinsten Club wo ne 10 20 Leute
manchmal kommen oder so ich mach die
heute auch noch gibt's natürlich gibt's
das also
aber wie kriegt das denn hin dass nur 20
Leute zu euch kommen dann müsst ihr ja
sagen wir treten heute nicht die ab also
wir hatten wir hatten z.B sowas gehabt
das war ganz doof organisiert da war in
Oberhausen Oberhausen OL eine der
größten Veranstaltung in Oberhausen da
geht wirklich jeder hin egal welche
Musikrichtung er hört egal was er geht
dahin und wir hatten 100 m Fußweg da von
dieser Location entfernten ein Konzert
gehabt an dem Tag und
wie viel Leute waren da 50
50 war wirklich zur Hochphase also wo
wir wirklich jeden Abend 4000 Leute hat
od sonst was dann wir da in diesem Club
wir den hier los nur 50 Leute aber die
Party war legendär und das ist egal
weißt du wenn die Leute Spaß haben dann
hast du auch Bock darauf weiß dann
denkst e hier sind 50 Leute die wollen
gerade 100% geben dann weiß also es gibt
echt Künstler die hätten gesagt nee
mache ich nicht hier das spiele ich
heute nicht und das ist uns egal also
wir sagen egal wie viele Leute kommen
wenn so 50 sind oder ob 000 sind die
Show wird gerockt okay wann hört ihr auf
oder wann müsst ihr aufhören wan
irgendwann ist man ja zu alt ist das bei
euch mit 50 60 7 80 90 wir haben
nachenfreiheit ich glaube dadurch dass
wir wirklich alle Sparten bedienen und
so können wir glaube ich noch mit 50
oder 60 immer noch auftreten egal W okay
ich mE ich mE jetzt mehr körperlich ach
so ja das kann man jetzt noch nicht
sagen spür das noch nicht so im Rücken
manchmal schon nee aber es ist wirklich
so also ich glaube Jürg dres stimmt
Beispiel der ist auch schon 35 und macht
das ist auch schon 35 schon 45 45 wenn
nicht ich hte jetzt auch so nee aber der
macht ja auch noch und da gibt's ja
viele Beispiele ne es gibt viele Leute
oder auch wenn du dir Udo Lindenberg
heutzutage anguckst der rockt auf der
Bühne der rockt noch also es geht es
funktioniert man muss glaube ich fühlen
wobei bei manchen denkt man wenn die
dann so alt werden auch wenn ich im
positiven Sinne natürlich man wird schon
ein bisschen Gager besteht das Risiko
aber das ist ja auch wenn du nicht in
der Öffentlichkeit bist so ne also Gager
wirst ja so oder so sind wir jetzt schon
wir sind ja schon Gager oder also ein
gutes Beispiel Beispiel ist mal wenn du
auf dem bauarbeitest wirst du auch
irgendwann gagger werden wenn die ganze
Zeit irgendwie die ganzen Kollegen um
die Ohren hast und so und dieich voll
laber und BL dann wirst du auch gagger
aber im Endeffekt machen wir das worauf
wir Bock haben wir machen ja unser Hobby
zum Beruf und das ist das geile daran
deswegen wird man nicht so schnell Gager
okay vor allem wenn man das
richti gut dann erstmal danke fürs
Interview danke auch und wer es noch
nicht genug hat dem empfehle ich seh da
Mun im Interview sensationell zum Thema
lieber obdachlos als Klisches spielen
und natürlich nicht zu verachten die
Interviews die die zzen gesehen haben
z.B mit flir das letzte oder mit hier
fahet Bang drauf klicken und angucken
wer Spaß dran hat also bis dann bleib
dran